first of all we're here talking about
screenwriters and this big competition
that these guys behind you have just one
talked to me about what you're gonna be
doing tonight Jimmy Chung ken Jeong and
blair Underwood and I we're gonna be
reading four of the screenplays that won
the Nicholls fellowship this year and
we'll just be doing I think it's like
one or two scenes each and just bringing
their words to life and getting to honor
them thank you I'm only doing it for the
five dollars something else what you
talked about wanting to do is a comedy
with your on-screen mom Sandra Bullock
when are we gonna make that happen do
you have what you want in mind I mean I
would love to do a comedy with sandy um
you know I'm available ocean's nine can
we make that happen
ocean land sky whatever you want I'm in
why do you need to do this cause this
one a lot of actresses and actors in
their 30s that's what they have they're
like big breakout role but one role that
was so powerful for you was to the bone
how has that role changed your life it
was it was very therapeutic for me to do
that movie to partner with Marti Noxon
on that I feel she's a friend for life
and I got to really connect with so many
young women and men out there who
connected to the storyline in the
subject matter and and have now shared
their stories and come out from may be
feeling shameful about their histories
and really embraced it as part of who
they are and moving forward so I just
feel honored to have taken a topic that
is so prevalent in today's society but
not really spoken about and giving it a
larger platform how do you do it eat I
mean I mean there's so many taboos in
society do you feel like it's made you
more body-positive since doing that
it definitely has I think you know doing
to the bone was a was a moment for me to
kind of take a step back and look back
at a time in my life from a new fresh
perspective and older perspective and
really I don't know just really
appreciate where I'm at and to be able
to speak more openly and honestly about
that time in my life and to encourage
others to do the same
and really just take out shame and
regret you know from our history and
again like moving forward to my 30s all
I want to do is feel fresh and positive
and I think to do that to shed that skin
now it was really important for me
personally and professionally and now
it's just I'm almost like a blank slate
is there something in your career that
you want to get off your bucket list and
you're 20-something oh my gosh well I
don't think that's me now in March I can
do a film with Meryl Streep I don't
think that's possible so I'm gonna put
out my list for the next 30 but I'm
really pumped to my thirties I can't
wait to enter into the new phase because
I feel like there's so many things I
want to accomplish and that's just you
know it's onward and upward
[Music]
[Applause]